we've got uh we've got a lot to talk
about here today first of all uh sona is
not going to be joining us on the
podcast and she has a pretty good excuse
she did give birth to her twins she has
twin
boys i think it's mikey and charlie
confirmed this for me is that right it's
is it it's
michael yeah it's charles and michael
but uh she calls him mikey and charlie
so she's embracing her armenian past uh
full-on
she now has uh these these two children
and um it's so funny
because i
became
like a a grandfather figure or something
i don't know what happened but i was on
the east coast i had to be on the east
coast when the babies came and i was so
nervous and i kept checking my phone and
pacing and my wife kept saying it's
going to be fine it's i'm like well i
haven't heard yet i haven't heard and i
was texting her
husband tack like any word what's
happening
and um then they came and i was like i
want to see pictures
pictures
and then i wanted more pictures and i
totally turned into
this i don't know like it was my
grandchildren at all upset with you that
you maybe didn't even act that way for
your own children yes
i said it's uh mikey and charlie and she
said quick what's the name of our
children i went well that that's neither
here nor there
that's neither here nor there here and
there yes their name is here there and
and there's a third that will be
everywhere that's all we need to know
but i uh i totally lost my mind i'm so
happy showing strangers look sona had
her babies and what's crazy is a lot of
people listen to the podcast so people
knew so i had people saying to me
so sona must be having those children
should not watch
last night look and i was showing them
my phone and uh walking around just
bellowing at people in restaurants i
don't often bellow but i was bellowing i
was very excited well you're a proud uh
uncle godfather guard what a role is
yeah i think um
evil
evil overlord uh
satanic brain clown brother
i don't know what my relationship is
but i i think of myself as uh uncle i'll
be uncle conan you sent me a picture
that morning of the twins before sona
had even texted you yeah you had them
that's how excited it was and by the way
let me make sure i i introduced david
hopping david hopping is the assistant
who's filling in for sona while she's
gone which means by law you also have to
be on the podcast yeah by law
so you uh david were uh were getting
excited texts from me and photos before
you even heard from sona right i was
yeah i was out to lunch and you said i
had messaged you about something
work-related and your response was have
you seen a picture yet and then sent one
with it yeah the proof that i do have a
human side he does thank you and it's
nice to let people know that do you
think people need to know that no okay
strange guy david very strange listen
i know that you
have designs on sona's career and uh
you're gonna try and take advantage of
the fact that she's out creating human
life to slide in here and uh become a
household name and i've got my eye on
you hopping it's been a five-year plan